nantes paris en handbike c'est le défi
de nicolas jean pierre philippe et yoann
quatre militants de l'association des
paralysés de france
parti le 25 mars une quarantaine de
kilomètres parcourus chaque jour et sont
accueillis par la délégation des mines
c'est une grande fierté parce que je
pense qu'ils auraient dans les mains de
courage qu'ils ont entrepris quand même
ça fait c'est un projet d'envergure mais
sa porte haut et fort les couleurs des
personnes handicapées qui se battent
pour eux mais aussi pour tous les autres
pour toutes les personnes nées oublier
un chemin pour toutes les personnes en
précarité
à chaque étape de cette marche citoyenne
des oubliés ils s'arrêtent dans une
ville pour discuter échanger les
distribuer leurs tracts je avec
mes bras j'ai une aide électrique sur
mon vélo pour les monter et non c'est un
projet vraiment magnifique
sait on est partis de nantes et on a
rencontré beaucoup de personnes
quand même 400 et quelques kilomètres
dans les bras pas dans les jambes comme
dirait l'autre
mais les rencontres qu'on fait font
qu'on peut repartir le lendemain
objectif de cette action faire entendre
leurs revendications autour du respect
des libertés fondamentales de
l'accessibilité au droit ou encore de
l'inclusion sociale
on va rencontrer les candidats
à leur qg pour leur remettre nos
propositions apf et pour se faire
représenter par toutes les autres
associations qui travaillent contre
toutes les formes d'exclusion
à peine le temps d'échanger avec les
versaillais nicolas jean pierre philippe
et yoann repartent arrivée à paris
prévue ce mardi 11 avril à 14h au
trocadéro pour un rassemblement citoyen